[Music]
schooled in television soap operas like
coronation street and brookside
liverpool-born frank cottrell boyce has
gone on to write some of the most
captivating british films of the last 15
years
it is his collaboration with director
michael winterbottom that has been
particularly fruitful
they have made six films together
including gritty docudrama welcome to
sarajevo the futuristic code 46 and
perhaps most well-known 24-hour party
people which reimagines two decades of
the manchester music scene through the
eyes of eccentric entrepreneur tony
wilson
frank is a versatile and creative
screenwriter able to convince across an
array of tones both serious and light he
is without question one of this
country's foremost screenwriters
this big tradition of screenwriters
complaining about not getting any notice
um i think there's a great there's a
great ben hecht quote it's easier to
become famous for riding the tricycle
than it is for writing screenplays
i've never had any problem with that at
all i think invisibility is a superpower
i think any attention you get is drawing
your attention away from what you should
be doing i've always liked the fact that
it's kind of an anonymous form and even
though i'm like someone who really
appreciates a good screenplay to this
day many of the best screenplays that i
really love i go around saying that's a
great script
i can't actually know i couldn't tell
you he wrote up
which i think is a fantastic script
well there's a funny thing that happens
because everybody says you know the most
important thing is the script the script
the script the script if you have a good
script you can make a good movie if you
don't have a good script you can't make
a good movie and at some point the
script becomes detached from the person
who created the script which is the
scriptwriter
um
and by the time you've actually made a
film
the script and the scriptwriter have
kind of disappeared
and it's partly a sort of historic thing
of the auteur theory i think the auteur
theory
is silly
i mean silly not just argue just
absolutely silly of course it's the
movie belongs to everybody who makes the
movie and
one of the glorious things about making
a movie i think is how important
accident can be and where they can be
and performances can be and things that
are very hard to try i think a
director deserves credit for being on
top of that quick sound
and kind of marshalling it all and
pulling something out of it but um i
don't have any problem with anybody
getting the credit for a movie really
i'm not really going to talk about
writing movies tonight i'm going to talk
about
enjoying movies and watching movies and
cherishing movies and why we like movies
it's a guy called pete skillman i don't
know if anyone's come across this but he
does this thing it's like a managerial
team building thing where you get a
packet of spaghetti and some string and
a marshmallow the thing is you get a
certain amount of time i think it's 10
minutes to build the biggest structure
that you can and then put the
marshmallow on the top okay it's got to
stay up with the marshmallow on the top
the people who are best at it
are architects
the people who are second best at it are
kids in kindergarten which are kind of i
guess you're gonna guess that
and there's there were two reasons and
one was the one that he kind of is
focused on and which i think is worth
thinking about
they're not afraid of failure they'll
just start if it falls down they'll
start again they'll just keep starting
again and they'll try different things
and they'll get through 10 different
models
but in those 10 minutes until they find
one that works and they're you know
they're great they don't kind of think
in towers they're thinking like wouldn't
it be great for a big dinosaur or a huge
flower or things like that and kids are
brilliant everybody knows that
but the other thing about the kids that
i kind of noticed this tweet but is that
they started with the marshmallow
and they built up with the marshmallow
because the thing that they were really
interested in was that marshmallow
and they started with the marshmallow
they kind of built up underneath the
marshmallow
and
that just seems to me really important
that the pleasure
the object stays central that you don't
get kind of frustrated around all the
architecture and the
the the group dynamics and things like
that it's the marshmallow that really
counts i think how do you do that how do
you keep your marshmallow in mind when
you're having all these meetings and
you're building that structure
[Music]
i think real life stories are almost
always more surprising and more exciting
than stuff that you make up the stuff
that we you know
the best
the oscar for best original screenplay
always seems to be a massive misnomer
because all the original screenplays
seem to be quite like each other was
best adapted whether they're adapted
from life or books or place or whatever
often quite interesting things are going
on in there because there's some new
energy coming into the film process but
i i just love interviewing people and
like talking to people and you know
writing is quite a secluded job and for
me it's always quite interesting to go
and meet people and talk to people and
and to try and catch something of them
and it also gives you a court of appeal
when people say you know
he doesn't seem to have learned anything
or resolved his issues you can just say
well he didn't sorry
he was a very slow learner he never did
learn anything well they don't seem very
sympathetic yeah
so
we won't say that's quite interesting
because that's got a strange
you can see the hollywood structure in
that because he gets the kid out and you
could have ended with that and you know
for better or worse i was always
intrigued by the fact that you had to go
back
and that her mother did appear in the
kind of messiness of war and the kind of
the fact that it's not really an ending
it's never really an ending
and that came from
just trying to stick as close to the
truth as possible i do think you kind of
get amazing things if you try to stick
as close to truth as possible and if you
can't do that then putting someone on
the screen saying this isn't true this
is what we kept doing in 24 hours
i don't think this is a good thing but
i've never done any of those courses or
followed those books or the guides or
anything so i kind of looked at them for
this talk in case i was missing out on
something because i've never written a
hit movie i've never done those things
and when i look at those screenwriting
books they're very focused on you know a
particular object making your film
getting your film made making your
filmmaker do the best at the box office
and those things are very very important
but something very dry and very
architectural very self-helpy
they read like diet books to me
and i was thinking how do you connect
with the pleasure of it all
when i talk to people about
screenwriting i always say to them first
of all are you sure you want to write a
screenplay because it's such a big ass
getting a movie made and there were so
many other things you could write that
might still end up as a movie so it kind
of kind of put that very that there are
other ways
through in direction direction you know
there are other ways to make a movie
apart from sitting down and writing the
screenplay you could write the play you
could write the radio play
you could live the life you could you
know whatever and that's one thing to
think about just what a massive
undertaking it is and what a huge ask it
is to get a movie made
i've actually had the privilege of
reading more frank scripts perhaps than
than i have of most other writers um and
his scripts are always
energetic you know you never think oh
there's a kind of long draggy bit here
you know there's always stuff going on
sometimes there's too much stuff and you
okay let's cool it down and calm it down
a bit but you never like feel like oh i
wish there was you know more happening
here
for most of its life
even a quick turnaround movie is going
to take years for most of its life
your movie
isn't moving
for most of its life your movie is a set
of meetings and phone calls and rewrites
and appointments and recces and
hassle and it's only in your head
that it's a movie and how do you do that
how do you keep that thing alive for
possibly more than 10 years there have
been
films that i've desperately wanted to
make all my life and never got made
and i mean it's so unpredictable isn't
it because there are films that i've
made before i finished typing we were in
shoot the real pain is not it's only one
in three but it's the wrong one of the
three
you know that's the real that's really
hard to deal with you know you should
have seen my other one because i know
that some people are just
thinking about writing and starting
about writing
two kind of mental tricks to play to
keep it pleasurable
right
so that to get you through those ten
more than ten years because when i read
those books like screenwriter books that
whole thing about three acts and
structure and that whole kind of
architectural vocabulary
what about putting something much more
subtle and much more kind of dynamic in
its place and talking about suspense as
a way of structuring your story suspense
is part of the rhythm of how we live
suspense is the gap between the question
and the answer between the birth and the
death between the gestation and the
birth between the will you and yes i
will between the i'll kill you and your
dead and that how amazing gap between
announcement and act
that the way those two events send a
signal to each other could be like a
string that puts any kind of pearls that
you want on it as long as that string is
sound enough and obviously you can make
it too sound you can be in that star
trek position of having a landing party
with spark bones and the other guy
[Music]
you can kind of make it too clear what's
going to happen
but it's that thing if i if you make it
clear enough that people are kind of
waiting
because you can't always know how a film
is going to end you know it's going to
end wrapped up and the thrill is that
delicious thing of sitting there
thinking i know where we've got to get
to i can't see how we can get there and
one of the most beautiful beautiful
examples that i can think of is the end
of the disney cinderella well you know
what's going to happen and the prince
comes around does anyone remember this
the prince comes around and says i'm
going to try the slippers on everybody
but cinderella is locked in the room at
the top of the castle how can she
possibly get out and then the animals
help her out and she comes down the
stairs and you think oh fantastic and
then the wicked step where the trips are
up
and the slipper is broken and it trips
the print up and the slipper is broken
anything how can you get you know you're
30 seconds from the end of the film how
is it ever going to get there and she
produces the other shoe
from my pocket
which she never knew i never thought
about the other shoe all these years 2
000 years of that story nobody ever
thought about the other shoe
fantastic
kind of delicious
thing between you know where you're
going to get to and you don't know how
you're going to get there i mean i love
in bruges just because it's like i don't
know what's going to happen next all the
way through it that's what i love i love
white ribbon for the same reason
um up
because i was really not expecting it to
die
no one had told me about that and
you know anything with that's
unpredictable i just think if you're
going to be if the enemy's going to
surprise anybody it should surprise you
first and i know that's really difficult
in a film situation because you are
asked to pitch things and i just plead
to allows the latitude to do that
because i think you know the endings
that you love tend to be things that you
know people have played lots of great
cards all the way through and then they
pull one back that you've always loved i
think of um
the ending of cinema paradiso
that film probably goes on too long it's
probably a bit over sentimental but that
thing about you know they were cutting
out all those kisses earlier in the film
and they come back and you can watch
that engine and just
without watching the rest of the film
it's such a great ending it doesn't need
a movie um
but it's that thing of like pulling
something
or the end of um
sideways
when he's been carting that book around
and it's a running gag and you think
that obviously nothing's going to happen
with that put and then one person reason
it's the right person and i was so not
expecting that and i bet the writer
wasn't expecting
to write that i know the sideways is
from a book but i get
and you can see sometimes that people
have worked you know i've played on you
know i've played a note that's a
beautiful note and just bring it back
and it it works
um
the end of the harry potter films
fantastic thing there's a throwaway
thing in the first harry potter where
harry goes to the zoo and the snake
responds to him
and
10 years later that turns out to be
absolutely axiomatic to who he was i
don't believe she knew that i think
that's like there's a kind of synergy
between picking you know throwing out
these great cards and thinking oh i can
play that one again and it's a i think
that's what that was inspiring that
engine i think
[Music]
there's another kind of suspense that
you can enjoy i think which really the
way the industry's structured quite
understandably really really mitigates
against you're constantly being asked to
predict
what you're going to write predict how
it's going to shape up how how things
are going to be you're asked to write a
treatment you ask like a step outline
you're asked to do the pitch and tell
people what it's going to be like
but
but writing isn't like that or shouldn't
be like that or at its best it won't be
like that writing should
at least for the first draft could you
not just throw yourself off the cliff
you know and see what happens
because you're not kind of there's a
great line in the hitchhikers like guide
to the galaxy about how to fly which i
think
beautifully explains that kind of
element of trust that you've got to have
to throw yourself into something which
is a really hard thing to do because
i think it's after dances it's very easy
to fly all you do is fall off a cliff
then get distracted
and then you'll find you're doing it and
i think it's that isn't it it throws off
off the cliff
and
you're constantly being asked to explain
what the ending is but if an ending's
going to be surprising shouldn't it
surprise you first shouldn't you not
quite know where it's going isn't the
best way i
i can use an analogy from chess actually
that if you if you play into a
particular ending in chess if you play
in particular if you're playing to a
particular checkmate the minute somebody
spots that you're stuffed
but if you just play for your strongest
position all the way through the game
then towards the end of the end game
you'd have three or four endings to
choose from and you'd choose one and it
will always look inevitable but that's
the great art of it that i always looked
inevitable
i loved saying that because i'm rubbish
at chess
i just thought i was looking out
thinking yeah frank chess so good and
the reason i know that so clearly is i
know one checkmate and i play with my
ten-year-old and the minute he sees it
it's like he's not tennessee he's 14 now
i'm in denial but the minute he sees it
the game is over but i know what it
would be like if i was good at chasing
it would be that place he's strongest
position all the time
and
my word of hope about that again about
how long this process is and how you
endure this process and how tedious it
can be and how you've got to keep
yourself together is that one thing that
people always ask writers about is
inspiration where'd you get your
inspiration where did you get your
inspiration how did you can you get me
some inspiration whatever it's like and
it's i think the map that is in people's
head is that inspiration is this
ignition key and that inspiration comes
at the beginning you turn the key and
you're off but inspiration often comes
at the very last minute the very best
inspiration comes after you've done all
the groundwork and you've
headbutted your way through draft after
draft after draft suddenly something
will come to life
and i think that's my message to to
anybody who's writing that you know
don't
don't despair of that hope that it will
come as long as you keep faith as long
as you keep trying that moment will come
the number of things that have been
rubbish until the last minute is legion
i went to seven stories a brilliant
museum in newcastle which is museum of
children's writing and i went with my
daughter and we saw the manuscript for
the borrowers do people know the
borrowers books
they're amazing books they're really
brilliant and there's the manuscript for
the borough is this absolutely brilliant
brilliant book and it's called it's not
called the borrowers it's called under
the carpet
it's like it sounds like a dyson advert
or something and the characters are all
got the characters and the borrowers
have all got these amazing names they're
called pod and homily and
skinner and these fantastic names and in
the original manuscript they're all
rubbish names they're all
sort of beatrix potter's names and
they're all sort of nicely typed out and
then crossed out and all the brilliant
stuff is put in
much later it can come inspiration can
come very very very late so that's
another thing that might help you endure
you see i don't think there's that much
wrong with borrowing if you've got great
taste i think it's about your great
taste isn't it and
in a way one of the things that i think
drives me to say oh you should just let
go at least for the first few drafts is
that lots of the rules about filmmaking
and storytelling are really hard-wired
in you you've been watching films since
you were a little kid it may not be that
you can sort of tabulate those rules in
a really crystal clear way but if you've
taken those in with your mother's milk
since
since worst spots you know
how
how a story works and it in a way i
wouldn't be that scared of being
derivative i think i think
isn't it great when you take something
old and put something of yourself in
with it i think that's the thing if you
put something up something that means
something with you to you
with with an old story that comes to
life again that
millions is the pardon his tail every
romcom you've ever seen is cinderella
what's what's wrong with that there's a
great line from italo calvino that um
the tale is not beautiful until it's
added to
i wouldn't be too scared of stealing
it's it's
having the taste to steal the right
things maybe
my process is fairly chaotic
and
i'm
i'm very dependent on
having good relationships with
people who believe that i'll pull it out
of the bag in the end because my process
seems to be i write a fairly average
sort of convincing first draft and
everyone goes you could do this to make
it better and then i go and really screw
it up completely for about three or four
drops and then suddenly i'll pull it out
with a bag
and that's my process for what it's
worth and it's very uh unconsidered it's
not i'm really bad at planning things
and i'm very polite so i'll go through
that whole writing a treatment thing in
my heart's never in that and it's never
very convincing but it's possibly just
convincing enough and then there'll come
a point at which i just think i have to
own this myself and i'll go away and do
something mad with it and it that will
either it'll either stand off for by
that draft really
he writes a very readable script so you
know the impression you get is that
you've watched the movie that's to me is
what when you read a great script is you
feel at the end of your hour and a half
two hours reading that you've just
watched the film and you're not
particularly sometimes he puts in you
know he puts in funny stage directions
and and you go okay you know that's a
nice that's kind of reward for reading
it you're never going to see that in the
film but it's fun to see it on the page
um but by and large i think he's a very
very economical writer he doesn't
flannel around and put in too much stuff
everything that i'm working on is in the
same notebook
it's like mine the kids novel that i'm
working on is in here but so is the
screenplay and so my railwayman notes so
it's all
for instance at the moment i'm working
on a children's novel
and the railwayman so that's these are
kind of story ideas for it and then the
railwayman meeting last week there was
some that's the description of how what
trains we got and what
shape eric was in and what colin said
about it and then there's my speech for
tonight
and so they're just kind of all one
after the other and then it's not sorted
out it's just
it just imitates my brain
so i don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
it kind of i guess time is one good way
of sorting things out so it can kind of
go through and go
oh my god it's agent since i've written
anything to do with that or whatever you
know
and you can rewrite too much this is um
i won't give you an extra uh
an example from my own work because it's
so true but i'll give you a story about
one of my children who um one of my
daughters told not not joke
no no should we do it knock knock
can you
can you let me in it's cold out here
right it's okay it's fine but she would
end that not not joke by saying
do you get it
it's because kenya's a really hot
country so you wouldn't be cold out
there okay
i should i should have said this before
she's quite a little
she's one of my smaller daughters right
so she said yeah can you let me it's
cold out there and it wouldn't be cold
and this meant a lot to her because her
brother was working in kenya at the time
and kenny was on her mind and africa was
on her mind and he was sort of imagining
it so she rewrote the joke
right so that people would get it
because people didn't get it and she had
to explain it to them like kenya was hot
so they weren't getting that so
she thought maybe kenya was too obscure
so she changed it to not not
africa
africa let me in because it's cold out
here
so obviously
now it's obvious and i don't know how
many times
i've been in the process
with the script editor or commission
editor who has seen very clearly
what people weren't getting which is the
africanus and has changed the script or
the idea so that people will get it
because they've had their idea about it
and it's the wrong idea and it's sweet
and it's touching but it is the wrong
idea and when you follow those rewrites
you kind of end up in the wrong place um
okay so that was just me talking about
um
that's you know that's a protracted
process we've talked about more than 10
years and rewrites and
humiliation and all those things and
what i kind of wanted to talk about
tonight is how
how you keep faith
through all that how you endure that
process how you enjoy that process how
do you keep
your movie in your head because for most
of its life
even a quick turnaround movie is going
to take years for most of its life your
movie
isn't moving
for most of its life your movie is a set
of meetings and phone calls and rewrites
and appointments and recces and
hassle and it's only in your head
that it's a movie and how do you do that
how do you keep that thing alive for
possibly more than 10 years
[Music]
i think frank's films are very diverse
and that's really interesting but i
think you can you can see some kind of
common preoccupations i think there's a
very strong sort of moral thread that
runs through them
um and that that's you know it's it's
kind of obvious in something like
millions where you have such strong sort
of catholic iconography and all the
saints and so on appearing but i think
also if you look at the claim or
butterfly kiss even you know those are
really powerfully moral films even if
they're dealing with very dark material
you know they take a position on things
um in a way that i think you know some
other writers or some of the directors
and writers wouldn't have done
and i feel that's quite characteristic
of frank i think he's very
humane as a writer he's really
interested in the intimate
detail and relationship of people and he
really cares about people and you feel
that in the scripts
i think you feel that
and that's an interesting counterbalance
because i think often michael
winterbottom is accused of being quite
cold as a director and i think frank is
very warm as a writer so i think again
that was an interesting
um
coming together of two people with
different sensibilities i'm going to
take you back for a few seconds to
the the beginning of cinema
uh and i want you to imagine that you're
in a russian town and i'll pronounce
this wrongly but which i think is
and there's a young man he's about 23
and he's he's at the fair it's easter
time he's at the fair
and he's sort of taking in what's at the
fair he's a real person
and
he's someone who's had a tough
upbringing he was often very young he
ran away from his orphanage and went
instead of with his grandmother and he's
just making his way in the world and he
would become a very great man
and great artist and a great
figure but this is the beginning of his
life right and he's at this fair it's
april and it's in muscovy
it's cold i imagine i don't know what
other people imagine that fur is going
to be like what's
what are you going to see at that fair
i'm i'm putting up dancing bears
jugglers
come on help me out here okay
anybody shout something
a bearded lady fantastic brilliant
but old babushka's selling stuff
a band playing maybe
and he goes to a tent and the tent is
called ormond's tent
and inside the tent this is what he sees
i just wanted to think about kind of
what it meant to be there at the
beginning and the kinesis of it and the
greatness of it and the silence and the
sort of transformative power of those
pictures because kind of from the
beginning has there not been kind of a
big gap in cinema between the lumiere
brothers going out and showing you
moving images of your town in which you
might literally see yourself in that
picture and on the other hand the kind
of melies
brothers
exhibition of wonders and amazements and
i was watching that and thinking about
that great line from rilke about if you
think your world isn't poetic enough or
exciting enough to tell a story about
that it's not because it's a dual world
that's because you're not poet enough to
wake his soul up
[Music]
you